we have a voicemail number 219 to david
p we had someone who had a very strong
and positive reaction to Pat Forde Kira
gate revelations also apparently liking
david pakman show coffee take a listen
to this hi this is anonymous from parts
unknown I wanted to thank Pat for his
bravery IQ and the Keurig user and after
hearing about the pats usage of reusable
Couric pods and V and yeah i'm david
pack and coffee i went and bought myself
some and I'm very much enjoying it and
now you used to use the pause all the
time and now thanks the pan I'm saving
helping to save the environment just
wanted to thank you and tell you how
much I enjoyed your coffee alright well
listen there's nothing better than
enjoying david pakman show coffee which
you can get a david pakman.com slash
gear my recommendation would be to use a
french press or chemex or if you get the
espresso Brenda's a splendid espresso
machine but I guess using recyclable
reusable Keurig pod is better than the
ones you throw out you know what I'm
done trying to hide from this
controversy I've I've even apologized to
those who about whomever I've offended
yeah I've tried to manufacture my own
scandals to make us yes tracked you know
I use the Keurig and I'm proud of it
okay well also I wow I think I'm going
to be visible described as visibly
shaken again as a result of this on the
bonus show today universal basic income
searches are trending why we will talk
about that an Indian engineer named
Saddam Hussein cannot get a job I wonder
why and mexican tourists are
increasingly opting for canadian
vacations over American vacations we
will talk about that and much more david
pakman.com slash membership is the
number one way to sign up for membership
in fact it's the only way to sign up for
membership you can also use the coupon
code i voted 17 to get a major discount
off of your membership we will speak to
you excuse me on the bonus show in mere
minutes